the mystery of old jack has been
answered where the time go back on
Tuesdays season two finale of this is us
fans finally found out why a seemingly
happy and healthy Jack Pearson appeared
in a teaser with salt and peppered hair
leading up to Jack's daughter Kate's own
wedding to her fiance Toby she'd been
dreaming about her mother and late
father's relationship and what should
have been had he not died in the tragic
house fire years ago some of you may not
know this but for the 22 years that I
worked for lundi builders my wife put a
folded note packed into my briefcase
every day it sort of just makes you the
wistful for what could have been us eats
he spoke with Milo Ventimiglia during
South by Southwest in Austin Texas on
Monday ahead of the finale where he
opened up about what it was like to step
into his late characters future three
hours of makeup in one hour of cleanup
it's a lot but you can't help but feel
like you're in your 70s years when
you're when you're in it I mean how I
was standing we were in between scenes
and I was talking to someone and how
standing eyes I couldn't get out of 70
year old Jack